[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kissen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today is the author of
irreversible damage the transgender
craze that is seducing our daughters
abigail schreyer welcome to trigonometry
oh thank you so much for having me on
it is a great pleasure to have you on
francis and i both read your book i was
going to say it was a great pleasure
reading the book but i actually would
say it was a great horror
reading the book because it it's very
difficult
to to read because you weave the stories
of individual people together with the
scientific data together with the
broader
societal issues uh but the personal
stories particularly of families have
been torn apart by this stuff
uh are very difficult to read and very
moving
and francis and i have been talking to
people for a long time about this we've
had trans guests on the show to talk
about we've had people like posey parker
on the show as well
and we really when we dived into it it
was very
sort of like why are people talking
about this stuff like what's going on
why is it important we didn't really
understand it we didn't really know
about it
and i think your book brings to the fore
the real world impact
of politicizing this issue so tell
people who haven't
yet read the book and i really recommend
everybody does
why did you write this book well i wrote
this book
because in the last decade there's been
an explosion of
young women teenage girls who suddenly
identify as transgender
often with their friends and want
hormones and surgeries and are easily
obtaining them
and the reason this is significant is
we've had it you know something called
gender dysphoria which is the severe
discomfort and one's biological sex
that's something we've known about and
had a 100-year diagnostic history of
so we know what it looks like and it
doesn't look like this
we've never we've never seen before
young teenage girls this was always
something that
afflicted little boys and men never
teenage girls and now teenage girls out
of nowhere the leading demographic
so whenever you see something like that
it's worth asking why what's going on
here
and that's all my book sought to do and
it's something that your book explores
brilliantly and incredibly powerfully
but let's start right at the very
beginning then
why is it that we are seeing this
explosion of
young girls prepubescent amputeen girls
wanting to transition
well the way to see this is it's one
part of a larger mental health crisis
facing teenagers generally and and and
teenage girls most acutely
um we know that teenage girls are and
even
tween girls so girls who haven't yet
reached teenage years but are in the
very beginning of adolescence
are experiencing rates of anxiety
depression and other mental health
problems that we've never before seen
the rates of suicide suicidal ideation
self-harm are things we've never before
seen and researchers who've looked into
this psychologist like jonathan height
and jean twangy have been able to link
it to social media
immersion that these young girls across
the west are immersing in social media
they're feeling very bad about
themselves and and they look to the
culture to help explain what's wrong
and the culture's loud and you know
instruction to them if is
is you know if you're not feeling great
about your body
you might be trans and
you say it's social media but what your
book does very very well is
is we use social media as a blanket term
but there's lots of different strands to
it
for instance you talked about instagram
the unrealistic expectations that young
girls place on their own bodies by
seeing
photoshopped images of other go of other
women and so on and so forth
that's right i mean social media sort of
conspires in a million different sites
to
make girls feel that they're not good
enough their bodies are
are bad or ugly that they are being left
out
they can watch their friends be at a
party while it's happening
who seem to be having the times of their
life and and and they know they they
haven't been invited to
um they watch how many likes their
friends get how beautiful the prettiest
girl in our high school seems compared
to them
they can actually quantify how many more
likes and friends she has
and it's a very very punishing thing for
a teenage girl to
to sit with and experience i mean one of
the things that people always throw back
at people like you who delve into this
issue is
well you know we've had as i mentioned
we had a transgender presenter
uh on our show called india willoughby
and we you know she was talking about
how
she knew she needed to transition at
five uh
as a boy uh to to being a girl that
didn't happen
she lived most of her her life as a man
it was very uncomfortable experience
very unpleasant and when she eventually
did transition
she felt very very comfortable and it
was it was really just a clicking into
place and that was great
so people will often throw back examples
like that at someone like you so what
what do you make
of that counter argument that well some
people need to transition and
you know why are you interfering with
that that's not a counter-argument i
agree
with that um i i actually have you know
in the book i interviewed many many
transgender adults
and i am someone who believes you know
very much and has been
i'm i've been convinced absolutely that
that transition can be very helpful
for mature adults who who have lived
with gender dysphoria as you mentioned
your guests did from a very young age
that's what gender dysphoria has
always looked like it's young it starts
in early childhood
and it's young it overwhelmingly has
been young boys saying no mommy i'm a
girl i know i am
um and it's persistent insistent and
consistent throughout their lives and so
as adult mature adults they make this
decision for themselves
my book really has nothing to do with
that it's a copycat phenomenon
among teenage girls who fall for
virtually
every major hysteria who with their
girlfriends they're in terrible pain
and what they do is they convince
themselves that no their problem isn't
that they're
too fat as they must might have said in
an earlier generation
what they the problem is that they're
really supposed to be boys
abigail and how has this happened
because there was a friend of mine who
explained it to me
in a way that i could never then not
understand that afterwards she said
in terms of transitioning of children
she said children cannot consent
right so children who are under the age
of 18 cannot possibly consent to
gender surgery or taking hormones in the
same way they can't consent to
drinking alcohol having sex or whatever
else it might be
how have we got to a position where it's
happening that
children are making decisions about
their long-term future in this way
you know there are a lot of lies told
around this and one of the most
um uh disturbing really is that
that a young child could consent you
know in america
each a young a minor is in is invited to
give
a sense to their you know for instance
elimination of the risk that they will
eliminate future fertility
by undergoing these treatments as if a
child could possibly gauge that loss
um it is a lie we we know that and
that's what the high court of justice
said in britain
when they you know in the kiera bell
case when they looked at it and
they said you know basically miners
under 16 have no way of evaluating
what it is to lose you know potential
you know
sexual function and and and fertility
there's no way for a child to understand
that and so but how have we got to this
place
where you have not even
not even just adults but professional
people doctors
psychiatrists agreeing that a
six-year-old should be able to take
puberty blockers
that's right we have a terrible problem
with with both
you know um bullying and unfortunately
cowardice in its face and in our medical
professions
um in in america the the standards of
all of the
major medical professional accrediting
organizations have been rewritten
to tell the medical professionals that
they must affirm this is affirmative
care
so whatever the patient self-diagnosis
whenever a patient self-diagnosis with
gender dysphoria
the doctor's job is to agree not to use
their independent judgment
but to agree with the patient's
self-diagnosis this is sort of the sort
of damocles that hangs over all medical
professionals today
and if they don't if they don't really
have the courage to speak up
they they just go along with what you
know
be out of fear of of repercussions and
loss of their license
and you will get to the fear of
repercussions because it's not
in any way unjustified the fear is
genuine because as you yourself know and
i say we'll get on to it
there are quite a lot of repercussions
uh but
what where's this i mean where's this
come from though
who is who are the people who are
rewriting these rule books and who are
the people who are advancing this
world view well the activists in this
area are particularly aggressive
um but i will say in america i think one
of the reasons we've been remarkably
um sort of immune to all evidence to the
contrary to all evidence the girls being
hurt i think that
britain's done a much better job here of
being at least open to that conversation
as in america we have a real weakness
for the idea that you can be anything
um and you know even if you want
the opposite sex now of course you can
present as the opposite sex
but we've actually completely swallowed
the lie that you can become
the opposite sex and of course the
problem with with swallowing
any lie in public like that is it leads
to more and more lies
so in california this just this week the
california insurance commissioner just
announced that breasts
you know in transgender identified
females including minors
would be considered abnormal
developments they would be considered
abnormal structures that need repair and
of course um
the the the problem there are many
problems with this but once you have the
lie
in place that anyone who believes
they're a
man truly is then you have to look at
breasts and say well that's an abnormal
structure i guess we
we need to remove it regardless of age
and abigail this is a question that i
find myself
asking many of our guests right across
political spectrums
when they're talking about issues such
as these but you do think
you know there's we talk about a lie we
talk about you know the light that
becomes the truth
but what happens to adults watching this
not standing up not saying what they
think
and letting children be irreversibly
damaged isn't that a form of
i do think so i i will tell you that my
my views on this changed in the last
year
um you know as i sort of faced a torrent
of backlash myself i
i i will say that you know my my inbox
has been flooded with parents
who are who are very grateful um and and
and
have gone through that with this with
their own kids and their own daughters
but it's also unfortunately been flooded
with doctors who say
gosh i'm going to lose my license but i
totally agree with you and for the first
time in the last week i finally replied
to a doctor you know
usually i just say to professionals of
all kinds listen i'm a journalist you're
not
go ahead and send me your documents i
can keep you out of it but for the first
time this
you know this past week i started saying
you know what the truth is you're a
doctor
and if you believe patients are being
harmed i'm sorry but i think you have a
professional obligation to say something
right right well this is this is a
running theme as francis says in our
show we've talked to a lot of people and
the answer
in in many of these issues is always for
people to be courageous
in in what are genuinely difficult
circumstances but you talk about getting
letters from parents you interviewed a
lot of people
uh in the course of the book you you
give some of their stories
what was the most shocking thing to you
that you discovered in writing this book
i think one of the most shocking early
lessons i got was when i started
interviewing transgender adults
and i mistakenly expected them to be
very energized and
and pushing transition but actually i
got the reverse from them
i got not only incredible sensitivity
sobriety and thoughtfulness
from the transgender adults i
interviewed but also they were very
honest with me that transition is very
difficult that it is not
a snap of the fingers that these
interventions are
are are really significant and of course
irreversible and that they did not
believe
that minor should be going through them
um and that teenage girls who suddenly
decide they were transgender
because their friends were all coming
out they did not think these girls
should be easy
should be fast tracked to transition in
fact they were horrified
and and really finding you know getting
to know all these wonderful
transgender people for whom the
activists do not speak
um was really a revelation to me
and the the thing that i found
incredibly shocking is is the language
that was being used
for surgery such as a double mastectomy
you know like
a top top half surgery or something top
surgery
it makes it sound almost frivolous but
then if you know
anything about mastectomies it takes a
six month recovery period
francis is an expert and breaststroke
are complicated structures they're not
they're not you know nothing
you're not you're destroying function
not only erotic potential but milk
production i mean
when in any other every of medicine
cosmetic surgeons are not allowed to
destroy human functions but here they
are without even a therapist note
even on minors and it was it was really
shocking to me they do call it surgery
they do pretend it's nothing
and they are amazingly immune to the
burgeoning stories of regret that are
out there if you look on youtube
week to week the number of young women
came coming forth and saying
listen i was convinced i was trans but
but now i see i'm not and look what's
been done to me
they're all over youtube and as you say
in the title of the book it's
irreversible damage uh
one of the arguments that people often
talk about
is the you mentioned suicidality in
general but
one of the arguments that's used very
specifically in this context is that
if you don't allow people who could
claim they need to transition
to transition you're you're causing them
to
to think about suicide you're causing
them harm in that way they're going to
kill themselves
what do you make of that argument you
know unfortunately i i don't think it's
a good argument and i'll explain why
unfortunately science and medicine have
become so thoroughly politicized in the
united states and
throughout the west but particularly in
the united states that that people
recite these mantras without looking at
any evidence it's
incred even scientists and doctors
especially the younger generation
are so woke as they say they're so
they're so activists they're not
interested and the truth of the matter
is we have no proof
that gender dysphoria causes suicidality
and we have no proof that medical
transition
cures it and especially not for this
population which we've never before and
seen
experiencing gender dysphoria they seem
to be experiencing
an atypical form of gender dysphoria
that comes on suddenly in adolescents
often with their peers
and as a result of social media
influence it doesn't look like typical
gender dysphoria
and we have no proof the transition will
cure it and in fact if you look at the
numbers
we're seeing more and more people not
being helped by transition who fall into
that
demographic and what responsibilities do
these social media companies have to
take because we've touched on it a few
times now
you look at some of these transgender
youtubers so some of whom have got
hundreds of thousands of followers on
youtube
how much responsibility do they have to
take for what is happening
well they're not taking any now they
they certainly aren't uh claiming any
responsibility look they
you know i think it was instagram
removed thinspiration sites so
sites that encouraged other girls in
anorexia because we all know that
encouraging someone does starve
themselves is a bad thing
but apparently encouraging young girls
to remove their breasts
or take course of testosterone that will
permanently alter their bodies in all
kinds of
dangerous ways um that's not considered
a
a bad thing in fact it doesn't even come
with a warning um
and and and that's really incense in
some sense that's the fault line here
my book does not say and i have never
said that no one should transition my
book does not say
that transition can never help my book
says
that there are risks here that these are
serious interventions and there are
risks
and if you believe those risks are worth
exploring and discussing
like every other medical treatment and
procedure then you're on my side
you talk about i mean france has brought
up the issue of youtubers and it's very
frustrating for us because they have
more subscribers than us but
seriously uh the the the the concern
there is
you know we have we believe in free
speech you have that is enshrined in the
american constitution
so people should be able to say what
they think right
i guess it's more a question of
protecting children isn't it
like how do you protect children from
the things people say online about
how great transition is or whatever else
it might be
um i don't know that we have uh that our
speech is so free right now in america
you know yeah yeah i mean parents who
were
you know dug into their own pockets to
try to promote my book because amazon
barred ads and
there were so many suppression efforts
and instant from from
from social media youtube has taken
certain of my interviews off and whatnot
and um parents dug into their own
pockets to put up billboards parents who
believed my book was
helpful to them and correct and had
watched their daughters gone through
this
put dug into their own pockets and put
up billboards across
and there was a campaign to do it across
the country and the billboards were
taken down
because someone claimed that that the
that a billboard which
which said um know the facts
um before making life-altering decisions
they said that constituted hate speech
in america
so the billboards were taken down know
the facts now you have to know to know
something about america you know that
every drug
requires an announcement and of every
possible risk
we're not allowed to prescribe tylenol
you know acetaminophen in america
without alerting everyone to every
possible risk
but but irreversible gender surgery
you're not allowed to talk about the
risks
francis how is your cyber security i've
got a virus from an unnamed website of
course you do
you're not alone francis during the
pandemic british
online infrastructure has faced an
astronomical rise
in targeted cyber attacks which is what
i'm sure happened to you
that is dreadful what can i do to defend
myself
that is where pockets seem come in they
offer businesses like ours a special
solution that alerts us to hackers
crackers and malicious employees like
anton
not only that they are the only scene
provided to offer pay
as you go cyber defense for companies
they're british based
absolutely and they're from doncaster so
they need the work
you say that actually they have kept
their prices flat during the pandemic to
make sure companies can get the
protection they need
pocket seam are offering trigonometry
fans a 10
discount all you got to do is hit them
up by email at
info pocketseem.com and
make sure the subject of that email is
trigonometry and they will give you your
10 discount
for managed cyber security that email
again is i
n f o at p o c
k e t s i e m
dot co dot u k and don't forget to have
trigonometry in your subject line
so you get your 10 percent discount can
i just say if you need
that spell you really shouldn't be
running a business
but surely there's going to be a
backlash to this
as we have seen in the uk where people
who were told that they could transition
as prepubescent little girls or
pubescent girls
will suddenly find that they're in their
early 20s their mid-20s they have been
let down by health professionals the
authorities etc etc
and they are going to inevitably sue and
so they should
you know i expect the lawsuits to come
but right now
in america this whole um you know
machine
of fast-tracking young girls of to
transition shows no signs
of slowing down and it's there's no
signs of sobriety
my book was pulled from target.com
because of two
complaints by twitter users um my book
was
it i mean there the number of i i am
constantly
uh facing all kinds of censorship and
all i've ever wanted to do
was discuss the risks that was it
well let's let's talk about the
censorship part of it because something
we've dealt with when we had uh
posie parker on the show that video uh
he was doing very well he got deleted as
hate speech by youtube
eventually reinstated and thanks to them
it's now nail on him on a million views
so we appreciate it but
it's something that people face whenever
they talk about this issue and many
others
where you're coming at it you know i
would say from a very constructive
sane sensible position you're trying to
look after vulnerable children
uh without being hateful or
discriminatory in any way and yet the
reaction is literally like you're trying
to publish mind camp
but but with your own take on it which
you know
and it's just so disproportionate it
almost like it's hard to believe like
my family live all over russia and the
former soviet union when i try and tell
them about some of the stuff that's
happening in the west
they don't get it you must feel like
you're living in some kind of weird
world
it's a whole different thing and not not
real
i'll tell you the kind of calls i get
and this and this happens week to week
a couple months ago i got a call from a
muslim man
living in our country in america who was
an immigrant
he was an immigrant from a you know he
was muslim and an immigrant from an arab
country
and was living in washington state where
the age of medical consent for
mental health services has been lowered
to 13
which means 13 year olds without
parental consent can
can get treatment gender affirming
treatment
but his child didn't seem to have gender
problems
his child this man's child who was a a
um i'll say an adolescent so a teenager
um was a minor and a teenager
um was suicidal and had had mental
health problems
so he checked this um
this teenager in to a um hospital
in washington state while for
psychiatric care while the teenager was
there they decided that the
child's problem was gender dysphoria and
they began
to proceed without the parents
permission to treat
the child for gender dysphoria and the
muslim man called me in a panic
because he said basically i don't know
what
in the heck is going on in this country
that i just moved to
i want to get my child out and i want to
get out of here
um please who can i call to get my child
you know um out of the hospital and i
you know i i was able to put him in
touch with a social worker who could
help
but he was only allowed to collect his
teenager
if he agreed uh uh that the teenager had
this new identity
and even then he had to fight to to get
his his teenager back
that that's the world we're living in
that's the world no one wants to talk
about
no that that that parents who have spent
i don't know hundreds of thousands of
hours
with these people with these kids and
and all of a sudden a mental health
professional comes in spend one 45
minutes
session with him with him or her and
thinks she knows better
and everyone has to listen to that that
that so-called professional
or or parents you know risk losing
custody that's that's what we're living
in
and abigail so they say it's a 45 minute
session but as you explain in your book
these children are effectively coached
by some of these influencers for one of
a better
term of how to go how to jump through
the hoops
how to make yourself appear to a health
professional that you have gender
dysphoria
could you explain the process of how
that works for these girls
so so by and large these these young
women are and
you know the first real research on this
was done by dr lisa lipman
a brown university public health
researcher who looked into this and she
hypothesized that there was pure
influence
and social media influence at play and
she looked at because
the fact that there was a burgeoning
number of of young
adolescents girls who out of nowhere
after spending a lot of time online had
decided they were trans
these were overwhelmingly white girls
middle and upper middle class
highly educated very precocious girls
who had a lot of anxiety and a lot of
depression and had a lot of trouble
fitting in
so they hit their teenage years they hit
puberty and they went
through a very painful time and they
went online
feeling very lonely and instead of you
know in prior generations questions they
would have asked
girlfriends like i hate my body what do
you think of yours that sort of thing
instead they turn to google they turn to
the internet to figure out what's wrong
with them
and the overwhelming message is you're
probably trans
wow i mean it's it's utterly
heartbreaking
and so they see that you're probably
trans but yet they're also
coached aren't they in order to find
what are the way through the medical
systems and the and the gaps in the
system etc etc
so i interviewed one young woman benji
from for my book on
an adolescent who um who had identified
as a young
at 13 she decided her problem she was
going through a very tough time
um at home and she she went online and
chose age selected a trans identity on
social media
and she was overwhelmed with
congratulations
and love and encouragement from adults
and adults who would then coach her
through
transition encourage her to break away
from her parents
encourage her that her parents could not
be trusted
celebrate her for this new identity and
many of them of course also wanted
um pictures of her because these were
adults
online you know some of whom were there
to prey on minors
it's it's a very very difficult subject
to talk about
um i mentioned it with you before the
interview this happened
to a friend of mine her daughter is 12
years old and she was telling me about
the she was obviously
very upset she was crying and she said
that her daughter
said the words to her uh and she was 12
years old
when i transition not if
when and to me
the the idea that a child would even
consider that
and let alone it for it to be a
certainty
is is completely heartbreaking and it's
child abuse
and and what's more it's not really how
children operate you can't really have
that level of certainty about something
when you're 12. you just
you don't know it's far more complicated
so
this is i think where francis was sort
of going out in terms of the coaching
these people are literally being told
how to go step by step aren't they
yes and i think the certainty is very
much the problem look we all have that
you know when you were
13 14 you're convinced that if i just
got my nose fixed if i just got
liposuction if i just all my problems
would go away it's so
normal for a teenage girl to think along
those lines
which and and of course they're getting
a lot of coaching and they're being
encouraged in this online
but unfortunately they're being
encouraged in their schools they're
being encouraged by affirmative
therapists they're being encouraged by
affirmative doctors everyone's
celebrating
telling them how brave they are if they
just go through with this
so what became a sort of adolescent
fixation
on the problem you know alleged problem
with their body
becomes in many cases almost an
obsession they can't
wait and unfortunately certainly in
america there are so many doctors who
can't wait to oblige them
do you watch problematic content online
of course they do they watch
trigonometry
many isps log your internet activity
and sell that data on to other big tech
companies
or other advertising companies i know
that is why i use
expressvpn to hide my browsing
activities i bet you do
expressvpn is a simple app that you can
have on both your computer
and your smartphone which hides your
traffic into one channel
and directs it through a vpn server
which means your isp can't see anything
that you're doing
look the question i want to ask no will
it slow down the videos that i watch
definitely not that is one of the
reasons it's been rated as the number
one
vpn app by cnet and wyatt i don't read
those publications because i'm not a
nerd
stop handing over your personal data to
isps and big tech companies which are
just gonna use it and sell it on
visit expressvpn.com
trigger that's e x p r
e s s v p n
dot com slash trigger i love it when you
spell things out but it gets even better
than that
expressvpn are offering trigonometry
fans
three extra months free go to
expressvpn.com
trigger to learn more i mean
what advice would you give abigail to
parents who see that this is happening
to their child
who are watching this and thinking this
is happening to my child i feel utterly
powerless i feel helpless
i don't know what to do what can i
possibly do
so it depends on the child's age okay
so um if your daughter is 11 or 12
or 13 and she decides out of the blue i
know what i
am i'm pansexual one of the things i
tell parents is
number one there's a very often pure
influence and social media influence at
play especially if she never exhibited
any kind of gender dysphoria in
childhood
which is you know a severe it's not a
tomboyishness it's a severe and
consistent
and insistent mental disorder it's a
it's a very severe
discomfort um it's not a pat you know
passing tomboy phase or even a committed
tomboy phase it's more significant than
that
um but but if she announces she's
pansexual
you don't have to raise the transgender
pride flag over your home
okay it's it's okay to just acknowledge
that she's 12 or 13 and her sexuality is
likely to develop and evolve
as she comes to know herself and as she
has
you know like real relationships a lot
of the girls who decide these things
do so after having zero romantic
experience
they don't know who they are or what
they want um they spend
all the time with mom and online so i i
think you know the younger they are
they're more
there's a lot more you can do to sort of
not
immediately encourage and solidify this
and perhaps get them some distance
from you know friends who are
encouraging it but also social media
social media is really pernicious to the
to all teenage girls it's just nasty um
and it's encouraging all kinds of mental
health problems
um so so you know so that's that that
the real
problem areas with when young teen girls
go off to college
and they're they're the age of majority
but they're often very very
immature we're seeing that a lot for
this generation and yet the moment they
step foot on college they now have
access to a whole array of gender
transitioning services that are covered
by their
college health plans abigail
and perhaps some even more appropriate
question might be what advice would you
give to parents
for whom that hasn't yet happened how do
you protect your child from being
uh swayed in this way let's say
well one is get them off social media i
i do think it's causing a lot of mental
health problems but the uh
you know do whatever you can to keep
them off it but the other thing i
you know if you haven't introduced it
don't the other thing is i would say
absolutely oppose gender ideology in the
schools
we are confusing an entire generation of
young people
in the idea that if they don't feel
perfectly comfortable in their bodies
they're probably a boy that is a very
confusing message and it's completely
untrue
and um you know kids are being taught
this and then the moment they experience
distress
the solution readily you know bobs to
the surface of their minds
um so i would say we can show absolutely
can show trans
compassion for transgender individuals
of all ages
without indoctrinating an entire
generation in gender confusion
all right well let me just put one uh
another attempt at a counterpoint the
argument that
people sometimes talk about is uh you
know
gay marriage and gay rights etc we as a
society didn't do well on that let's say
it took a very long time for gay people
to get equality
and uh you know the three of bigots like
us are just here
sort of doing the same thing with trans
people
gay experimentation being gay
comes with no irreversible harm
there is nothing if this were about a
generation of girls
declaring themselves lesbian or
declaring themselves pansexual
i would not have written the book okay
we wouldn't oppose it either abigail
right
i mean that's not what this is about
there is no harm
in gay experimentation there is
irreversible harm
in young girls teenage girls rushing to
medical transitions they are likely to
regret
because they have misdiagnosed
themselves with gender dysphoria
and no adult no medical professional you
know used any
medical judgment to evaluate if that was
an accurate diagnosis
and abigail isn't part of the problem
and you touched on this in your book
that we have a generation that we have
molly coddled we have protected them
from every single thing that life could
have to offer because we want to protect
them we want the best for them
we have a very very immature generation
we've just touched on that now
who are even more malleable than before
because they haven't come into real
world crisis
that's right and they haven't had sex or
even a kiss
these are young girls who have never
kissed a boy through their teenage years
going online to discover who they are
and what they want they have no
idea but from a very young age they've
been presented
with a buffet of gender options and a
buffet of sexualities
that they choose online like their
choose a sweater
they have no idea who they are or what
they want they've never as you said
they've been so molly coddled
and so protected by mom they've never
had the opportunity to discover
any their feelings for themselves so
so they so they what they when they try
to break free of mom when they try to
individuate they go online they do it
there
they get celebrated and they choose very
extreme
options um because they they really just
don't know themselves
let's move on uh and talk about the
political side of this
and the the censorship side of this
because this is something you've
experienced first of all
just before i get into my question tell
everybody
what has happened to you and your book
as a result of you publishing it
it's just been a non-stop you know both
smearing and libeling but
but also um censorship attempts first
from you know amazon refused to
allow my my publisher to sponsor ads
for the book so if you typed in the the
words for my book or search terms
they would suggest another book one of
the
hundreds of gender books that celebrate
teenage gender transition
target removed the book after two users
claimed it was
you know transphobic um you know
what billboards parents dug into their
own pockets played for billboards
to advertise my book the gofundme they
used to create a fundraiser to pay for
these billboards was shut down
even though over 30 000 fundraisers are
allowed on gofundme to pay for
for top surgery for breast surgery but
but
a fundraiser for parents who just want
awareness of the risks that was shut
down
the billboards themselves were taken
down it has truly been
endless why do you think
people feel so strongly or maybe not so
strongly but why do companies like
target amazon et cetera
why are they so fearful of of a book
like yours
well i think that the you know people
underestimate the
sort of two questions okay first of all
we're seeing the same
woke reaction among a lot of a fearful
reaction to these
you know young activists these young far
left activists
in all our mainstream institutions in
america now um and core in
corporations okay they're they're
terribly fearful we're constantly doing
anti-racism training and
and whatnot so you can see it as as part
of that but but the question is why this
book in particular
why um why this issue in particular
and i think that's the reason is is
because look my book's not political
it's just a journalist investigation
into this
you know sudden epidemic what's going on
here and why
and i think that if you take an honest
look at the book if you dare have the
opportunity to read it
you will be so horrified by what's been
allowed to go on
that you will immediately be you know
extremely concerned
um and you certainly want more
safeguards for these teenage girls
and i think that that the interests that
are committing to
committed to fast tracking as much
transition as possible for as many as
possible
they're they're they're pretty upset
that anyone would question them
and abigail why is it that this topic
inspires such vitriol and the bullying
and the anger and the harassment and all
these tactics that are used
why is this particular issue so toxic
because i'm right
because they know i'm right if they if
you read the book
you i mean just give it a read
you don't have to agree but just give it
a read if you dare
read the book you're most likely to be
horrified by what's going on
oh no doubt about that as we said right
at the top it's it's a horrifying
very beautifully and well put together
but horrifying read
but i think france's point is
interesting because i was just sort of
thinking you could probably drop the
n-bomb live on
on-air and you would get less of less
push-back than
than you've had even though obviously
those two things are not comparable
being racist is terrible whereas what
you've done is you're trying to protect
people
so it's interesting that that that that
seems to be the level of vitriol
why why is it even a political issue at
all abigail
it shouldn't be it really shouldn't be
most of the parents who write to me are
liberal
but unfortunately the the hard left has
so corrupted our institutions
even our you know from even our
scientific journals
um you're we're now seeing just just
bald you know politically
um motivated conclusions and papers that
really have nothing to do with the
science
and it really is from this young
generation of activists
who who aren't who are um you know very
much
activists first and doctors second
so could you give an example abigail
about you know where
activism is more important than science
a particular paper or
so on so forth well i think the
new england journal of medicine just
came out with something
um recently where they said i'm trying
to remember what what what the
particular thing is
maybe it was either trans women or women
or one of these
statements um but but you see it all
over i mentioned the california
um insurance commissioner just this week
um announced that
you know um that surgeries on
females breasts even minors would no
longer be considered cosmetic
they are reconstructive because breasts
healthy breasts are abnormal structures
see once you start with one lie
that a girl who identifies as trans is
really a boy you end up with so many
lies
in public and that's that's what we're
seeing just a complete blizzard of lies
in the united states
well that's the thing that i think
brought this to our attention somewhat
as i said initially it was an issue
i mean i honestly will tell you two
years ago before we
really started delving into in any way
we were like why is this important like
who
because we didn't really understand the
nuances and then you started seeing all
the stuff you've got
a six foot four person competing in the
olympics against other weight lifters
and winning all of that and people
literally fighting each other
one of whom who's gone through male
puberty and the other person being
beaten
and badly injured and you start to see
how
the reality really has become
placed on the altar of whatever this
thing is whether you call that
political correctness or politicization
or or gender ideology or whatever it is
it seems to we've just completely thrown
reality out of the window in this issue
haven't we
we certainly have certainly in the
united states i mean
um you know the house in our our
congress just moved to eliminate
all gender terms from the effectively
the bylaws the
you know what what can be said in the
halls of congress so if if this
you know passes there will be you can't
say mother and father any longer in
in um in congress truly concepts that
are at the heart
of of what it you know human life are no
longer
things that you're allowed to say for
fear of offending someone
but there has to come a point abigail
surely there has to come a point
where the lies unravel you cannot build
a structure
on falsehoods surely at some point
there's going to be an emperor's new
clothes moment
won't there so if i didn't believe that
i wouldn't have written the book
i i do believe that that the the truth
will
eventually out and and um
and i do believe it's it's sort of right
there before our eyes
so um you know that these procedures
need oversight that there are risks that
transition is
not easy that there are very very
significant health and medical risks
and that a lot of these girls are self
misdiagnosing
um and and you know we need to take a
look at that that all of that just it
strikes me as obviously true
you know what i find interesting about
it as well you know you've obviously
written the book
you know the subtitle is the transgender
craze seducing our daughter so you
haven't exactly
you know gone in easy on it you've gone
all the way
but there are people like jk rowling who
who've written things
in a much more um i don't want to say
new ones because your book is very
numerous as well but less
antagonizing way let's say to most
people right and yet
sorry am i am i not being fair there if
you go
you're being fair um you know i get a
lot of flack for the title of the book
um i i i will say a few things in
defense of the title
first of all there is irreversible
damage because you know
you know unnecessary medical transition
is irreversible dynamic
definition and this is a craze um
um because it creates it it is meets the
definition of a craze which i
which which i explained in the book it's
a sociological term
but but the question is is it seducing
our daughters
now i will just say um i don't know what
your experience is in england but
first-time authors
rarely write the title of their book so
i don't know why everyone assumes i'm
very different as a first-time author
that i was allowed to choose mine but
let's
let's um i would say that i'm i'm
certainly to be held accountable for
every word within the book
but um you know you know do i do i
pretend that i
came up with the title i mean do it does
any author
right no no i know what you mean i'm
working on my first book as well and
i'll make sure i get to pick the title
based on your experience
but where i was going with it is more uh
that there are people who have been less
direct on this issue
and yet the vitriol they've received has
been just as bad
as you have it's almost like like jk
rowling being a good example
you know what she said about it was very
very carefully worded
and yeah she is this evil bigger
transphobe
you know god knows what she is getting
death threats and whatever
it why why are they just
so vitriolic i still i'm we're probably
asking this question for the third time
in the last 45 minutes
i just don't understand well there's a
whole lot of people who are very
invested
in the idea that they are heroes that
they're saving
these girls from suicide and if they're
wrong
then we'll have to look at what they've
done very differently and we might even
look at many of them as monsters
that's a good point it's a very very
good point
i mean you look at this issue and the
more you delve into it the more it
becomes more horrifying the
more layers it has and the more it
unravels
what options are there for a girl after
she's transitioned and
she decides she wants to be she wants to
reverse it can she ever go back to how
she was or is it
too late at that point well it depends
what she medically went
underwent but i will say this i have
interviewed many transitioners they're
wonderful courageous
young women who went through something
very awful
and i will just say there is it's
important to remind anyone out there who
regrets the transition that there is
life after transition
there are cosmetic procedures you can
get to help with all kinds of
changes to your bodies and and and to
remember that you have a whole long life
ahead of you
and um you know i i try to stay very
you know make sure they get that message
because a lot of them do feel very very
bad about what they've been through and
what what they were what they
the procedures they underwent that said
of course
you know i wrote the book because the
changes that that a body
undergoes through testosterone cannot
all be undone the voice is likely
to be masculinized for life the features
may be depends how long she's been on
testosterone but she may have a
permanent five o'clock shadow
the changes to her private anatomy may
never go back
of course if you've had your breasts
removed they do not come back
um if you've had to have undergo a
you know prophylactic hysterectomy to
avoid endometrial cancer from the
testosterone
you know you of course can't have
children um so you know these
you know what's involved in transition
is a long series of very serious
surgeries and
and hormonal treatments and you talk
about before we wrap up you talk about
going through a lot
what has the last period of time since
you since you wrote the book been like
for you
well it's definitely been interesting i
mean
i will say this you know um i try to
stay
positive i get a lot of wonderful
comments from parents and i really
appreciate that i
had a lot of wonderful you know thanks
from trent
from both from doctors and also from um
um therapists who are who are very
concerned with going what's going on but
also from transgender adults
so i try to focus on that if you look
too much at the efforts
of suppression in the united states you
know perhaps in your country as well i
don't know but certainly in the united
states
it's it's very very dark um it does not
i mean the number of
efforts to slander me um and and
to erase my work it just there there's a
relentlessness to it
so i try not to focus that and and try
to focus on
um the fight ahead which which i believe
i will
win um abigail why did you decide to
write a book about this out of all the
possible things that you could write a
book about it's your first book like
you've mentioned before
why this why this topic why this issue a
reader wrote to me
and she said she was a mom she said my
daughter got caught up in this she had
no history of gender dysphoria
she had a lot of mental health problems
went off to college and decided with her
friends that they were
all trans and they started a course of
testosterone and the
woman was very upset she said she had
written to many journalists and no one
would take this cause up
and at first i thought this is the last
thing i want to get involved in
and i tried to pass her on to another
investigative journalist and then i
waited for four months
and no peace came um i was assured that
the piece would be written it wasn't
and so during those months i thought you
know if a journalist won't take this
up if a journalist won't look into the
biggest what could be
and i didn't know at the time the
biggest medical scandal
um you know around today then who will
ever expose this
well before we last you our last
question
let me ask you this how do you think we
will look back
on this period in human history and the
things that
that we as a society have done and have
allowed to happen
i think with shame and regret these
girls are teenagers
they don't know themselves youtube is
now being
flooded with stories of regret that the
idea that we can't
you know put more safeguards on to make
sure that only people
only mature adults who actually have
gender dysphoria
go through transition is is it's it's
crazy that we don't have those
and lastly the question that i i really
want to ask is
there have been links between autism and
then these girls transitioning
how much truth is there to that is is is
there a real link or is it or is
this expect simple speculation no no
there's been some studies on it there is
a link they have been able to show that
a high
percentage of you know there is a you
know a is certainly a length that a lot
of the girls who are
claiming to have gender dysphoria also
have autism you know are
on the spectrum so they have sort of
very often they're high functioning
these are highly precocious girls
high functioning uh you know autism um
but
um that was something i wasn't
unfortunately able to explore in the
book because
um when i began to interview um
um experts in autism as i did i started
to realize that that was such a scandal
of its own because
many autism doctors you know autism kids
with autism tend to fixate
and all these autism doctors
unfortunately
were introducing gender they were in
gender ideology they were
introducing a fixation to a population
that tends to fixate
so i i do believe it's a mental medical
scandal all its own
wow well you've got the material for
another book in there haven't you
uh abigail thank you so much for coming
on the last question we always ask
all of our guests is what is the one
thing that we're not talking about
as a society that we really should be i
imagine of course
the subject of your book would be number
one on that list but uh what would be
another
you know that that polite lies do not
belong in the public sphere
polite lies are the things we utter in
private but the moment as a society we
adopt
what we consider to be a polite lie to
avoid offending someone
we end up in a very very bad place
because
lies lead to more lies and they have
consequences in the public sphere
that they don't have in private so i i
think that's something we should
we should be talking about that's a
really good point and very own brand for
our show because that's the type of
conversations we like to have honest
ones like this one
abigail schrei thank you so much i
really recommend everybody read your
book
uh irreversible damage uh and thank you
very much for coming on
thank you thank you very much if people
want to find you online
abigail where would be the best place to
be after we've been slamming social
media for the best part of an hour
i think uh twitter of course uh at
abigail schreier
perfect we'll make sure to include that
in the video and thank you all for
watching we will see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or a live stream all of them go out 7pm
uk time
take care guys and see you soon